monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre à
cohésion des territoires
madame la ministre un rapport de
l'assemblée nationale sur les zones de
revitalisation rurale zrr préconise de
recentraliser le soutien à leur ruralité
un rapport récent du sénat ou
préconisent de tenir compte de la
réalité de renouveler ce dispositif de
soutien aux territoires ruraux les
ederer sont vécues comme un dispositif
de justice tout en respectant la libre
administration territoriale l'utilité du
dispositif ne fait aucun doute
notamment en offrant une fiscalité
adaptée aux acteurs économiques qui font
le choix de la ruralité des sept
générations fiscale en sont la preuve
sont porteuses de le lier d'attractivité
et soutiennent nos tissus de proximité
or votre politique au service des
métropoles abandonne la proximité
pourtant essentiel en ruralité aussi la
re centralisation étatique war étatiste
de vos décisions et mal vécues par nos
concitoyens dans nos villages qui y
voient un pouvoir central qui gère dans
os encombrants dé tenir compte de leurs
besoins
nos citoyens ruraux attendent désormais
de vraies mesures et pas seulement de la
com ils craignent cette recentralisation
avec la réforme que vous envisagez des
ederer madame la ministre
comptez-vous mettre fin aux ederer est
transféré de dispositifs et des moyens
dans la del terre et ainsi mettre fin un
support économique essentiel